that he continues to advance
his readiness should he choose
to
to go down a military path here should
he choose to invade again
he is doing
all the things you would expect him to
do
to make sure he's ready for that option
or options
there's no indication for example that
what they've called exercises have ended
in any way or are
changing in any way their presence
i want to be careful to characterize
another nation's exercises we've seen
them conduct these exercises in recent
days
exercises are designed to make you ready
and that gets to my previous point he
continues to do the things that you
would expect one to do if if one was
planning on a major military action and
that is to to sharpen the readiness
and to add to the capabilities of his
force now look
um
we obviously don't want that to be the
outcome
and neither do neither do the ukrainians
and certainly neither do our our nato
allies and uh foreign minister lavrov
said uh earlier today that uh or seemed
to indicate that he still thinks there's
uh oxygen here for diplomacy we we would
welcome uh a pursuit of that path uh by
the russians because we too believe uh
that there still
should be and can be a diplomatic path
forward are you still suggesting that
putin has not taken a decision to invade
ukraine
we
still don't believe that some
final decision has has been made then
how is it that
communications continuing we just heard
from president zielinski that he's been
told that an invasion will happen on
february 16th which is wednesday how do
you
reconcile sure putin hasn't taken a
decision but an invasion is happening on
the 16th well i'm not going to talk
about specific intelligence assessments
i think you can understand that we have
said for a while now that military
action could happen any day
and you heard from the national security
adviser
making it clear that it it certainly
could happen before the end of the
olympics uh maybe even this week
we have
shared with our allies and partners and
that includes ukraine our assessment of
the information that uh that we've been
receiving
and
certainly have reflected in those
conversations our deep concern about the
continued capabilities that mr putin has
at his
as it is backing call so i won't get
into a
specific date i don't think that would
be smart i would just tell you that
it is entirely possible
that he could move with little to no
warning what will the u.s response be at
that at that time the defense secretary
is going to the nato ministerial
are we talking about the nato response
force being activated what would we
expect to see president biden has made
clear that
should there be another incursion into
ukraine that
that the united states would respond
swiftly with severe economic
consequences i won't speak for the
alliance a decision to activate the nato
response force is a decision that the
the knack has to make the north atlantic
council has to make that's not something
that
that the united states would
unilaterally uh call into uh being i
will only add this
and this is why a couple of weeks ago we
talked about
making
our contribution to the response force
more ready and so we've done that uh and
one of the messages that the secretary
will carry with them
to nato is that
our contribution to the nato response
force should it be called should it be
activated they'll be ready to go and
just to be clear your answer to bob you
do not see evidence that his forces have
moved into attack positions yet i'm not
going to talk about uh
what specifically we're seeing on the
ground uh when it comes to unit by unit
what i would tell you is
that we continue to see him advance his
readiness
and improve his capabilities and provide
himself more options should he decide to
take another to take military action in
ukraine president biden spoke today with
prime minister boris johnson of the
united kingdom
the leaders discussed their recent
diplomatic engagements with ukraine and
russia
they also reviewed ongoing diplomatic
and deterrence efforts in response to
russia's continued military buildup on
ukraine's borders and reaffirmed their
support for ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity they discussed
efforts to reinforce the defensive
posture on nato's eastern flank and
underlying the continued close
coordination among allies and partners
including on readiness to impose severe
consequences on russia should it choose
further military escalation i thank you
for the question we are actively working
uh to reach a diplomatic solution to
de-escalate the crisis over the weekend
as you all know the president
spoke with with president putin and we
remain engaged with the russian
government in full coordination with our
allies and partners the path for
diplomacy remains available if russia
chooses to engage
constructively
however we are clear-eyed about the
prospects of that given
the steps russia is taking on the ground
in plain sight this is something that
the national security adviser jake
sullivan talked about right here on
friday
right before our eyes what we're seeing
with russia new russian we're seeing new
russian forces have been arriving at the
ukrainian
border every day
as we have said before we're in the
window
when an invasion could begin at any time
we will not comment on any details of
our intelligence information except that
except to say that it could begin this
week despite a lot of
speculation that it would happen after
the olympics again something that
jake sullivan said right here on friday
it remains unclear which path russia
will choose to take the u.s is ready
for any situation you know president
biden has made it very clear on his call
with putin this weekend that if russia
undertakes a further invasion of ukraine
the united states together with our
allies and partners will respond
decisively and impose swift and severe
costs on russia we only continue to see
a buildup not a de-escalation uh so we
are open uh to diplomacy that door to
diplomacy is open as we have said
and uh and so that is what we're
that's what we want to be headed towards
and you know if
we we will be ready uh for whichever
decision that president putin decides
but clearly we would we would prefer the
path of diplomacy i also want to just
say one more thing really quickly this
is something that
my
colleague kirby said john kirby said at
the department of defense just now that
secretary austin is going to travel to
belgium poland and lithuania so that you
all have this
the secretary is going to meet with
allied defense ministers and nato
leadership to discuss russia's military
buildup
in and around ukraine reiterate the u.s
commitment to article 5 and continue the
alliance's progress on deterrence and
defense while ensuring the alliance is
prepared to face uh tomorrow's challenge
so let me start by saying this we don't
take this sort of action without the
most thorough deliberation
and over the course of the last few days
these deliberations have led to a series
of staffing changes
in ukraine
we feel all of these actions were
absolutely necessary and decisions were
made with one thing and one thing in
mind and that is the safety and security
of u.s citizens and our colleagues on
the ground
now let me tell you what made this
necessary
russia's continued escalation and
seriously threatening military posture
as we have all seen in recent weeks in
recent days we are basing our assessment
on what we are seeing on the ground with
our own eyes which is a continued and
unprovoked
russian buildup on the border with
ukraine
and
no accompanying evidence of
de-escalation
it is a distinct possibility perhaps
more real than ever before
that russia may decide to proceed with
military action
with new russian forces continuing to
arrive at the ukrainian border
and russian forces staged all around
ukraine an invasion as we have said
could begin at any time
should putin decide to order it there
would be widespread human suffering
all the while we are actively working to
try to reach a diplomatic solution and
we remain engaged with the russian
government following president biden's
call with president putin over the
weekend
but since no one has full visibility
into president putin's decision making
and there hasn't as i said before been
any tangible sign
of de-escalation
we have taken the prudent steps of
updating the travel advisory for ukraine
to urge u.s citizens to leave ukraine
immediately using any available mode of
transportation and now most recently as
you saw just a little bit ago we are in
the process of relocating our diplomatic
staff from kiev to levite
the staff in lavif including our charges
christina kevin will remain engaged with
ukrainian government coordinating
coordinating on diplomatic efforts we
will continue our close coordination
with ukraine as well as with our allies
and partners
russia
if it sought to do so has failed in its
goal of dividing the united states and
our allies and partners if anything we
are more united
as we confront russia's threats and
aggression